Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This episode is about a classic, the Dunning-Kruger
effect. I wonder how we could go on for almost
60 Two Minute Papers episodes without the
Dunning-Kruger effect?
Here is the experiment: participants were
tested in different subjects, their test scores
were computed, and at the same time, without
the scores, they were asked to assess their
perceived performance.
The test subjects were humor, grammar, and
logic. Things, of course, everyone excels
at ... or do they?
And here is the historic plot with the results.
Such a simple plot, yet it tells us so much
about people. From left to right, people were
ordered by their score as you see with the
dotted line. And the other line with the squares
shows their perceived score, what they thought
their scores would be. People from the bottom
10 percent, the absolute worst performers
are convinced that they were well above the
average.
Competent people, on the other hand, seemed
to underestimate their skills. Because the
test was easy for them, they assumed that
it was easy for everyone else.
The extreme to the left is often referred
to as the Dunning-Kruger effect, and the extreme
to the right, maybe if you imagine the lines
extending way-way further, is a common example
of impostor syndrome.
By the way, everyone thinks they are above
average, which is neat mathematical anomaly.
We would expect that people who perform poorly
should know that they perform poorly, and
people who're doing great should know they're
doing great. One of the conclusions is that
this is not the case, not the case at all.
The fact that incompetent people are completely
ignorant about their own inadequacy, at first,
sounds like such a surprising conclusion.
But if we think about it, we find there's
nothing surprising about this. The more skilled
we are, the more adept we are at estimating
our skill level. By gaining more competence,
incompetent people also obtained the skill
to recognize their own shortcomings.
A fish, in the world of Poker, means an inadequate
player who is to be extorted by the more experienced.
Someone asked how to recognize who the fish
is at a poker table. The answer is a classic:
if you don't know who the fish is at the table,
it is you.
The knowledge of the Dunning-Kruger effect
is such a tempting tool to condemn other people
for their inadequacy. But please, try to resist
the temptation, remember, it doesn't help,
that's the point of the paper! It is a much
more effective tool for our own development
if we attempt to use it on ourselves. Does
it hurt a bit more? Oh yes, it does! The results
of this paper solidify the argument that we
need to be very vigilant about our own shortcomings.
This knowledge endows you with a shield against
ignorance. Use it wisely.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!